So, we've seen in this lesson how intelligence, creativity, and problem solving
are similar yet distinct. Intelligence is our ability to understand complex
ideas, to think abstractly, to reason, and to remember and successfully use
information to solve problems. Creativity is the capacity to think or in behave
in both original and adaptive ways. And solving problems can be done
systematically, step-by-step, or by sudden and unexpected insight. We have to
shed mental blinders we bring to problems if we are to solve the really
difficult problems we face. Remember to always try to think outside the box. We
hope that this lesson has helped you better understand the nature of
intelligence, creativity and problem solving. And better yet, that you will be
able to solve problems on your own more intelligently and more creatively.